absolutely wild story out of Washington
the FBI charging two men they say we're
posing as Homeland Security agents in an
influence operation that targeted four
Secret Service agents including one that
protects first lady Jill Biden the two
frauds appearing in court today they're
accused of lavishing the agents with
pricey penthouses iPhones drones and
even a two thousand dollar rifle the
four agents being placed on paid leave
Dan I'm going to come to you first were
you basically just been saying how is it
possible that this happened well I mean
I said the good news is they were caught
the bad news is how long it took to do
that they're also when they went into
their apartment you got to read the
stuff that they had in their apartment
lots of ammunition spotting devices they
were obviously plotting and planning
something and you know
I would love to know what they were up
to and I'm sure that we probably will
and thank you to the investigators who
figured it out the Secret Service better
tighten up its Counter Intelligence
efforts here and you know you could not
get into the United States capitol for a
year without six forms of ID how did
these guys actually infiltrate and to
get to have somebody that they had
basically had given one of these free
Apartments was on the first ladies
detail right that's disgusting and I I
bet I bet Joe Biden I've been the bidens
themselves but the president of the
United States must be furious right now
absolutely so this has been going on
Greg since 2020. he's agent or Foe
agents have been working and they also
were able to have a number of meetings
with government contractors and
government workers which opens up a
whole other can of worms about what
people might have told them I'm not
interested in the story
I was just doing the an apple bomb
impression so you have uh you have fake
agents protecting a fake doctor
I'm kidding I'm joking of course she's a
real doctor she certainly has a lot of
patience
worse than Watergate this is worse than
the Insurrection all right you know but
think about how many institutions there
are that have been compromised and how
you had the PPP fraud was 500 billion
dollars right you have journalism fraud
you have Intel agents colluding with you
know the media you got black lives
matter fraud or justice system
thank God our election system is
impervious
what do you find
they see what happened I had a bag of
chips in the brakes
who told you to have a bag of chips you
did okay you want to hammer me
YouTube
okay you can play clean up okay here's
the deal uh what concerns me is that
these guys have a lot of money they had
a lot of access to people they never
should have had access to the first
lady's security detail to her bodyguard
in particular we're talking about SWAT
vests large safes computers high-powered
telescopes internal surveillance cameras
access to very expensive apartments and
expensive buildings there is someone
behind this and I'm concerned not only
for you know Jill Biden and anyone you
know within that sphere but I'm
concerned about the Secret Service I've
been hearing too much about them in the
last 10 years with all these breaches
and that's all I have to say because
they said I have to stop
Jesse in a normal presidency this would
be covered
for two weeks and would be considered a
major national security breach on the
highest level the Secret Service was
compromised by Foreign intelligence from
possible Iranian intelligence or
Pakistani intelligence but in this
presidency
with Joe you got border crisis crime
crisis Ukraine
punter as we've covered this is just
another small ball Scandal but this
actually is probably more serious than a
lot of the things but this isn't Joe
Biden's fault no but you know it's a
culture of corruption Jessica yeah there
you go it is and this isn't really
happening right no it just did
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else